ah
character inexplicably falls down over
phantom object while running from danger
cliche not one of those girls gave a
good god damn about trigonometry finding
this surprising also trigonometry i
probably shouldn't say this but
some of these kids yeah no big loss if
we're honest yes that is something you
should categorically not say as their
former principal on the record to what
you believe is a journalist those girls
were special
they were
they were champions assessing one's
worth by how good they are at sports and
not even a real sport
soccer we're talking about here this
clearly isn't a real soccer game there's
a total of six points scored according
to that scoreboard welcoming anyone to
new jersey bringing this picture so far
off center that it makes me think
someone went back in time accidentally
made out with their own mother and
caused the third person to be erased
from it
not telling your partner they have bad
breath i mean how are they ever going to
know if you aren't honest with them and
provide some gentle direction we
wouldn't never play the music but
teenage girl listens to supernova in a
tv show set in the 90s cliche
no i fell into the tape deck and i
accidentally pressed play excuse i use
whenever someone catches me listening to
boom boom boom boom by the vengo boy
somehow makes it into the script also
you're welcome i decided on a color
palette for our room of rutgers next
year pink and green
it's like classic preppy meets palm
beach or kermit the frog meets miss
piggy it's a fine line never long enough
to count title of my sex tape you're
just gonna think we're like saluting
mediocre baseball chicago cubs fans
they are not we've got masturbating in
your daughter's bed and masturbating
while looking at pictures of your
daughter's teenage boyfriend well i
don't think the show's painting this is
flattering i do think the episode's
introduction to adult sean is making it
really hard to ever root for her and
it's just
yeah
here we see the biggest unanswered
question of the entire series prints or
styles
not interested sorry what if i told you
the others were then i would say that
you're lying
so you are still in touch look there
could be a lot of reasons why sean is
certain that the others won't talk
perhaps it's the shared trauma or their
mutually assured destruction or
hesitation to admit that they were
actually in limbo all along and that all
the mysteries people are harassing them
to share actually have very
underwhelming answers and are nowhere
near as satisfying as anything you made
up in your head yeah i'm still mad about
lost i'll never be able to look at a
cherry slurpee the same way again and i
blame you yellowjackets what am i
supposed to do just stand there and then
what happens everybody in jamba juice
just starts getting online wherever the
hell they want saying online when you
mean inline i don't care if you were
using that expression before the
internet the internet's here now and
that's where the term online should
remain oh my god what did you do you
literally never told them honestly if
we're left saying the same things after
six seasons i will yes i'm still mad
about lost when things get tough out
there those girls are gonna need someone
to guide them you handle that this is
the nationals which means the team has
played a whole season with jackie as
their captain shouldn't the coach have
found this out before the season even
started all right let's hear it for the
boys let's give the boys a hand that had
to be a reference to denise williams but
tim if that song came out in 1984 is it
just to show us that the principal's out
of touch if so why do i give a [ __ ] what
can i do to help
want a shot of tequila i wanna quickly
in the bathroom i fail to see how
bathing's gonna help the photo shoot
situation but i suppose we all have our
own coping mechanisms play like a
[ __ ] team and win
it's worked so far everything works
until it doesn't kid philosophies all
right bring it in take a knee ladies it
doesn't happen often but my finally
tuned you might regret those words later
radar is pinging like crazy am i
removing a sin for foreshadowing we
shall see keeper calm don't move her
coach scott is basically the only adult
character of any substance we see in the
90s sequences and he proves quickly to
be very much useless the show almost
feels more believable if this is just a
town of kids yellowjackets of the corn
pondering shoe tying more shoe tying
excitement might not be as bad as it
looks you could see her [ __ ] bones
jackie natalie would be buzzing at tv
sins thinking that a teenager in 1996
would have a reality bites poster in
their bedroom i'm not even sure this
would be believable in 94 and that's the
year the movie came out this is not how
you eat an apple she's talking about
taissa's little plant oh please since
when do you give a [ __ ] anyway i'm
guessing at least since earlier today
when she was telling taissa how [ __ ]
up her plan was to freeze out ally
i love some of the things that are being
set up here but this pilot is 50 high
school melodrama and all i want to do is
get back to the survivor meets the hills
have eyes mash up you are a terrible
dancer and you have seriously
questionable taste in music
and you can hold your liquor for sure
but you're the only one who's always
been there for me using three wrongs to
make a right fear and loathing in new
jersey i will raise the baby out of
spite and train it to become a killing
machine that eventually hunts you down
tv show thinks it's okay to steal my
movie treatment from 1990 and pass it
off as a joke shawna is a to bunnies
this episode gets plenty right but one
thing i especially love is how it
creatively works in visual clues to the
present and the past instead of just
having characters spouting out
exposition we wouldn't dare play the
music but playing the paloma faith cover
of never tear us apart instead of the
nxs original will always get you a sin
remember the most important thing is to
have fun this [ __ ] guy i'm not saying
this lightbox over here is a deliberate
[ __ ] tv since but it definitely seems
aware that we would send the fact that
this room is dark as [ __ ] despite the
daylight a lamp and light bulbs just
feels like they chose a backlit
profanity instead of dealing with said
lighting sorry i'm late i envision a day
where the english language is done away
with hello and how are you and replace
them exclusively with i'm late or you're
late in honor of every damn tv show and
movie that thinks this is just how every
conversation must start if someone's
digging
we are all [ __ ]
take care of it if you keep talking this
loudly then you're probably regardless
this server may not have been in the
shot but their reflection in this window
definitely suggests they were close
enough to at least partially hear this
public figure running for office being
threatened also why do people think a
diner is the best place for these late
night meetings wouldn't a bar be less
conspicuous you know somewhere that
people actually do meet up who's coming
to a diner at 9 00 pm for coffee unless
they're planning a heist having an
affair or attempting to keep the heinous
acts they committed somewhere in
northern canada buried as deep as their
classmates sitting this far away from
the fire when it's cold enough to be
snowing
[Music]
you hid christina ricci from us for 50
minutes
does gloria want to piss off misty
because that's how you get ants i mean
piss off misty although food on the
floor is actually how you get ants as
well
[Music]
this creepy score is so
damn creepy and incredible and creepy
damn you yellowjackets for earning back
the sins i work my ass off to find
assisting someone with their oxygen mask
before you have your own on dammit coach
they say it at the start of every damn
flight for a reason breaking the fourth
wall at the end of an episode cliche
he's a chicken
he's a chicken
hello up there i seem to have fallen
down a cliff i'm still alive but i'm
very badly injured ray he's kicked the
ball now the ball's over there
that man has it now
that's an interesting development
maybe he'll kick the ball
there is still everything to play for
and forever to play it in so that's the
football coming up watch it watch the
football watch it watch it he's gonna
move watch the football it's so gross
fear is the path to the dark side
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate
leads to suffering
shouldn't we say a prayer first yeah
knock yourself out please god
spectacles testicles wallet and watch
that's gonna leave a mark
i was pouring sweat
my blood is too thick for nevada
i've never been able to properly explain
myself in this climate